- But y'all are in for such a great hour.
Not only do we have an
incredible lineup of guests
that I'm super excited about
because I love this franchise.
What?
But we've also got puppies.
(audience cheers)
We've got puppies.
And it's incredible.
Do you wanna come here?
(audience coos)
That's right.
It's National Puppy Day.
Snuggle up.
I already have two dogs.
This is so dangerous.
(audience laughs)
So we have a pen of
some of the cutest ones
on set right now.
And the best part is y'all,
all these little guys are up
for adoption through our
friends at Paw Works.
And you're gonna want one.
They're so great.
It's actually fitting this
is National Puppy Day y'all,
because we have the cast of
"John Wick: Chapter Four"
with us today.
(audience cheers)
I love the John Wick movies.
It's a wildly successful franchise
in which dogs play an important role.
It's actually why all of
them started, is the dog.
The John Wick movies
have been so successful,
they led to multiple sequels
as well as video games,
comic books, a spinoff film,
and an upcoming TV show.
Am I gonna get this dog
and name him John Wick?
Maybe.
Many critics call this the best
action franchise ever made.
"John Wick: Chapter
Four" is in theaters now.
It's incredible.
If you like action, this is your movie.
And starting us off, please
welcome John Wick himself,
Keanu Reeves!
(energetic music)
Happy National Puppy Day!
Do you like puppies?
- Happy Puppy Day!
- Oh my God.
Look, they all came to you.
Is this the John Wick effect?
Do you do this?
- This is the John Wick effect.
- We might have to get the one.
(puppy whimpers)
- Okay, okay, okay.
Yo.
Buddy.
It's okay.
(audience roars)
Whoa!
(Kelly laughs)
It's a puppy-pede.
- I think we need help,
I think we need help.
- [Keanu] Fellas?
Fellas.
And misses.
Hang out for a second.
We're gonna hang out.
- We're gonna hang out.
- [Keanu] We're gonna be okay.
We're gonna get you some love.
- This is called the
John Wick Effect, people.
- [Keanu] We're gonna hang out.
We're just gonna chill out.
- [Kelly] We're gonna chill out.
- We're gonna chill out.
We'll be back.
We'll hang out.